wir wollen jetzt direkt live nach beirut
schalten dort wurde das außenministerium
gestürmt von demonstranten mein kollege
sebastian prengel ist vor ort sebastian
was kannst du uns jetzt live über diese
demonstrationen berichten
das haben wir am eigenen leib erfahren
doch braucht einiges abbekommen
es ist auch gewaltexzessen gekommen wir
haben immer wieder in der menschenmenge
demonstranten bewegen wir uns mit stark
blutenden wunden gekommen sind
das ganze ging hier so ungefähr um vor
ort zeitlos sind was den 1000 menschen
gewesen gibt auf die straße gegangen
sind
im stadtzentrum von beirut ist unweit
von diesem völlig verstörten hafengebiet
das sind menschen die bei dieser
schrecklichen katastrophe am team stark
mensch oder angehörige verloren haben
oder freunde sind menschen die
vielleicht auch ihr zuhause verloren
haben und wie gut dieser menschen die
endlich auf die regierung dazu muss man
zwischen der präsident des libanon soll
die frau orten gegeben haben was er von
diesem 2700 tonnen ammoniumnitrat
gewusst haben soll
die hier im abo kann bei uns schon seit
jahren gelagert wurden
er wusste um dieses pulverfass die
verantwortung dafür übernehmen will er
allerdings nicht
stattdessen sind funktionäre des hafens
unter hausarrest gestellt worden und das
ist einer der gründe warum die menschen
jedoch hüten cent gaben in der menge
heute menschen gesehen die sich aus den
überresten ihrer häuser geigen aus holz
gebastelt haben das ist ein deutliches
zeichen an die regierung ist
unmissverständlich was damit gemeint ist
und das haben uns auch so gesagt
die demonstranten wenden sich gegen die
politische elite in beirut was fordern
sie denn konkret was jetzt passieren
muss
naja also die menschen fühlen sich von
der regierung hier einfach im stich
gelassen wir halten die regierung
gerufen das wie man ändern
man sieht dass hier auch ein bild was
uns hier zum beispiel schon seit tagen
immer wieder erfolg ist dass sich die
menschen viele junge leute studenten mit
besen und schaufeln unterwegs sind
sie verlassen sich nicht auf die
regierung das hier irgendwie etwas
passiert dann die räume die stadt selber
auch ja und das ist bei weise sogar sehr
gefährlich weil die häuser sind ja
einsturzgefährdetes fallen immer wieder
stürmer tyler herab die menschen
verletzen sich aber es ist ihnen egal
die wissen ganz genau wenn sie ihren ich
selber anpacken dann macht es keiner
wie reagierten die polizei derzeit auf
die ausschreitungen
ja das habe ja gerade eben schon
angedeutet im einsatz gekommen wir haben
immer wieder bewerten granaten
explodiert denn die rauchwolken zogen
dann auch in die demonstranten hinein
das haben wir auch gemerkt und studenten
auch die augen war schwer zu atmen viele
leute hatten auch brillen an um sich
davor zu schützen und die polizei wohl
auch mit gummigeschossen auf die
demonstranten gefeuert haben wie ist
deine einschätzung dein gefühl für diese
stadt wie es dort jetzt an diesem abend
weitergehen wird
sagen also auf jeden fall dass dieses
inferno dass ich hier und drei tagen
abgespielt hat ist natürlich nicht der
einzige grund für die proteste
das land befindet sich in der
schlimmsten wirtschaftskrise in seiner
geschichte und es kam immer wieder zu
demonstrationen in letzter zeit was
heute
der ausgang ist völlig offen sebastian
hummel in beirut vor ort vielen
herzlichen dank für deine einschätzungen
wir bleiben natürlich hier weiter dran
danke erst mal